last night while guest hosting jimmy
kimmel live rupaul very briefly weighed
in on the republican senator ted cruz's
most recent
anti-lgbtq comments yeah cruz recently
shared why he thinks the u.s supreme
court was clearly wrong in its landmark
in 2015 for the o burger fell and uh
versus hodge's ruling that legalized
same-sex marriage during a podcast on
his youtube channel and mamaroo put
crews in his place with four simple
words
senator ted cruz says that the supreme
court was clearly wrong
about its 2015 same-sex marriage ruling
in gayer news
child ted cruz
period
period okay so rue's remarks come amid
growing fear that the supreme court
which recently eliminated abortion
rights protections by overturning roe
versus wade could soon take action
against same-sex marriage reversing
their 2015 decision and this isn't the
first time rupaul has provided a voice
on this topic sharing his sentiments
about the supreme court in his statement
after the drag race competition
franchise earned 11 emmy nominations
earlier in july writing as the basic
human rights of lgbtq plus people are
being threatened once again i want to
thank our peers in the television
academy for acknowledging the
achievements of the beautiful and
talented souls that work in front of and
behind the cameras at rupaul's drag race
i can't believe that these are the
discussions we're having in 2022
i can't
it is insane to me it's infuriating
um and i just i don't understand why
it is expected that everybody has to
have the same beliefs like what kind of
world are we living in how do we grow
and evolve
you know as a society like just as
humans when we're forced to believe
other people's belief systems and it's
like
maybe you're not catholic maybe you're
not muslim maybe you're not like
whatever your beliefs are doesn't mean
everybody has to
live by them like you're supposed to we
have one life to live it's such a short
span of time we're literally like dots
when we look at it from like a universe
perspective we're like a little grain of
sand and a blip in in the life of the
universe and yet we are arguing and at
war about these things that like do they
really affect your life like do you
really care if if people of the same sex
get married
like do you really care what women do
with their bodies like why are we like
guys it's just i don't know it just it's
making me insane yeah no i agree but
it's still you know it's still amazing
that we're still fighting as women of
color like we still fight every day
that's right um so
it's nuts
it's blown away
like and you know what when this
happened when roe v wade happened the
first reaction was like what's next what
are they gonna take away from everyone
and and it's so i and i've been obsessed
with the whole conversation roe v wade
where the supreme court judges came from
there they were you know they were
actually groomed in in law school to
make sure this would happen when they
would become part of the supreme court
and this is going to go on forever
they're going to try to change
everything and anything around it is
incredible to see when republicans say
something they make it happen while the
democratic say things and it's a
conversation
and like come on step up this is it's
out of control and i i hope the rights
are not taken away from the lgbtq plus
uh community because we fought so hard
to make sure that was in place i just
don't know what's going to happen next
it's so much anger and i think everyone
is feeling this anger right now that
we're actually living this moment in
2022
and i'm thinking i i even said it to my
kids and i think i've just had this
discussion before um you know she asked
me about it my older daughter and i go
you know our generation is failing you
we are failing you in terms of what's
gonna happen for you for the next when
you guys grow up like now i'm telling my
kids you know what these states you
don't need to go to school don't even
think about university about going to
these states like one day it's going to
be don't go to the us at all right like
these are the conversations i'm having
and i'm like these are how many supreme
court people i made that decision and
it's just it blows my mind these top
whatever 10 people made that decision to
control women so there's so much to it
but i hope it doesn't happen and and i
think this is where we draw the line and
we need to step up i know i'm canadian
but this is a trickle-down effect to
effect
right so
it's a tough one it's a tough one
it is it is a tough one and i'm just at
this point you know we're so you know
this generation we're very involved in
cancel culture and work we cancel
celebrities for saying the wrong things
and and sometimes you know yeah you need
to people need to to be woken up with
their uh beliefs and all that but can we
get some cancer culture for like the
government
why aren't some of these people like can
we start like some of these people are
dinosaurs
it's like there's 300 people in in in
america and there's a very small amount
of people that decide
how we get to live our lives like can we
start canceling some of this
what does the president do there's like
there's these three reforms they're
supposed to stabilize people's decision
it shouldn't be the supreme court fully
taking control of this like what has
happened why isn't anyone doing anything
it doesn't it blow and i you know i
don't know all the american politics but
there has to be a way to make this
happen not this and that's where we're
going we're going like this and it's
it's out of control some of the comments
we're getting uh what is going on in the
u.s hugs from barcelona ladies uh thank
you uh we uh where we the gays still
have our rights and women are getting
more rights right we oh well that's in
barcelona that's good to hear people
need to put their efforts and energy
into things truly affecting our nation
and our world health human induced
climate change education so um
you know i think all of us are just it's
so twisted right now keisha i don't even
know what to think about it anymore
yeah i just
i am a girl i am infuriated okay
all right let's just we gotta move on
it's friday it's friday okay
all right